dans l'autre série aventure aux à
l'ouest nous sommes heureux et fiers de
vous présenter une superproduction
cinémascope et en technicolor
intitulé d'après descendeur de tom hicks
en français le retour de tom mix avec
dans le rôle principal
rodgers pierre ce big star entourée les
célèbres acteurs rollmops tomato ketchup
les deux petites jumelles les soeurs
blue jeans et sofia du plantain la
vedette qui pousse c'est une
superproduction de la métro goldwin
meyer
kolingba of my taylor is rich rock my dr
isna wayne callies embrasement mesdames
et messieurs excusez mon camarade il ne
sait pas que vous ne parlez pas tous
l'anglais alors voici si vous le voulez
bien maintenant la version doublée en
français de l'eau chaude automix le
retour de tom mix c'est à dire que nous
allons donner une voix françaises à ses
lèvres américaine n'est ce pas version
post synchronisée comme on dit au studio
le gène villiers dans la scène auto 883
merci
soit reléguant content de vous revoir
ouais je vous avais dit que je
reviendrais cinq ans jour pour jour je
suis fidèle au rendez-vous pas vrai nom
l'âge la guerre ne sera pas déterrer du
conte et des montagnes rocheuses aigle
noir m'a dit la vérité
celui qui a tué jerry collins est ici
parmi vous ouais mais tu as dit qu'il va
y avoir de la bagarre
vous êtes pompiers eux savent bandits et
les autres ouais seul bic a fait le coup
a perdu un éperon à sa botte gauche a
été trahie weston tu as gardé ta bonne
gauche et l'assassin n'avait pas des
poussettes est un piège où je pars
baisse comme nous je vais faire feu à
tant pis pour toi
pas terrible c'est pas faire l'effort
on dirait de l'eau chaude
justice est faite sur la table pour
reprendre le droit chemin liban la
guerre de sécession à ccc sont encore
là-bas la guerre de sécession et finit
pas en vrai et nous devons nous remettre
au travail
enfin si content de vous revoir sa mère
comminatoire rire intelligent
bref là aussi je me sens tout timide
chéri vous avez quoi faire je voudrais
tant vous et vous est compté est ce que
votre père est décédé
il est pendant le viol un pardon
est ce que votre bd décider si beau
trouver son père une minute pour sûr je
vais monter sur mon cheval et je ne
dirai qu'un mot
mon désir mentionné gêner puisque ce
genre de son choix les jeunes dirait
qu'un mot la mega man je peux pas lire
là et je ne dirai qu'un mot chéri c'est
moi d'abord
wa al marri je me suis je pense à
quelqu'un de très grands maîtres en
colère catelli lui tous comme des lapins
si fort
eric nous d'attendre quoi la vie de
votre père vous avez grossi bon c'est la
choucroute oui nous allons nous marier
monde en jaune rossi loges
nous allons nous marier mélange dans la
petite église en france pour ses
figurines et devant toute la famille
bruni pour sûr nous serons unis pour la
vie oui vous mettrez votre belle robe
blanche et vos gros chaussures à clous
et nous partirons tous les deux d'un pas
tranquille sur le chemin du bonheur
c'est fini au parent de monde
à